こんにちわ
はじめしゃちょーです
何だ今のは！
何か今日も嫌な予感するんですけども
今日はちょっとガチャガチャで面白いモノを見つけたので
買って来ました！
こちらです！
能面根付２
魔除けの仮面
まあ僕はこの部屋でいろんな事をやってきましたし
心霊チックなこともやって来たので
ひょっとしたら僕の部屋はもう呪われているかもしれない
僕の後輩の妹で凄い霊感が強い人がいるんですけども
ひとりかくれんぼをやった後に
あの部屋何かいるよ？
はじめさん大丈夫？
あの部屋マジでヤバイよ！
みたいな事を言っていたので
ちょっと実は怖いです
なので、そういう魔除けの意味も込めて
今回、この魔除けの仮面
５つ買って来ました！
このガチャガチャを買いに行ったとき
とんでもない現象が起きてしまった！
あれは僕が何となく動画を撮っていた時だった
このガチャガチャは一回300円
300円を入れて
レバーを回すと
出てこない
戻したりもう一回ひねったり
一回戻しからて回してみたりしてみたのだが
出る気配がない
だがここで事件が起きた！
しばらくガチャガチャしていると
600円になって帰って来た！
恐ろしい！
じゃあ、すぐ開けて行こうと思います
こんなのホントは買いたくないんだけどね
魔除けって書いてあったからさぁ
何か効果とかあったら嬉しいなって思って買っちゃいました
1個目！
うわぁー！
うん。
『小飛出』という名前の仮面らしいです
神様らしいですね
これは
ブサイク
魔を払う仮面と書いてあるのでもうこれを持ってるだけで僕は魔除けの効果があります
助かります！ありがとうございます
何だ今のは
何か今日調子おかしいな
もう1個開けてみましょう！
出た！
うわぁー、うわー。
何なんだろう
これ『痩女』っていうヤツですね
ああ、幽霊なんだこれは
おお！
冥土の苦しみ見舞われている幽霊の顔を表す面らしいです
怖っ
普通に気持ち悪い
やっぱこういうのに魔除けの効果がありますからとてもありがたいです
ありがとうございます
何なんだよ！
何かすっごい嫌な気配を感じます今日
とりあえず、早く魔除けを！
魔除けを開けて行こう！
3個目いきます！
はっ！
かぶった！
今の所この3種類です
4つ目行きましょう
はっ！
うわ、
またヤバそうなの出たぞ
これなんかあれだな
千と千尋の神隠しの何か温泉に来た神様みたいな顔してます
『黒色尉』
これちょっと分かんないんですけど
怖いですね
非常に怖い顔しております
いやでも、こういうにちゃんと魔除け効果があるのでとてもありがたい
うう！
何だ今のは？
くそ！早く魔除けを！
魔除けを！
駄目だ完全にこの部屋やっぱ呪われてる！
ヤバイ
魔除けよ！効いてくれ！
頼む！
はっ！
はじめく～ん？
フッ
まさか
う〇こー！
うわわあわわわ－！
トミックさん！何でここに？
う〇こー！
何てクオリティー何だ！
凄いね
ヴィッティールまでトミックさんそっくりだ！
ウェッヒヒヒヒヒ
くしゃみ音
なにこれ！